hi there Steve coffin here it's a
glorious day here in Vancouver's sunny
and warm it's the warmest day so far
this year normally I'd cover the
sunlight to get a better sort of
lighting for the video but it's just
such a glorious day I decided I would
leave the sunlight you know
flooding in here I want to talk about
making language-learning real and how
important that is to our success and I'm
gonna refer again to my most recent
experience with Romanian I had a goal I
had to go to Romania and that really
focused me on learning Romanian and I
think I learned quite a bit in the two
months that I had to prepare largely
listening and reading I was able after
the first three weeks love listening to
sort of more basic patterns and some of
the simple content we have a link I was
able to find radio Romania radio Romania
listen to news history and this kind of
thing plus and the second month I had
about 5 hours a week of discussion with
my tutors but I was still stumbling
it's amazing what basically I guess four
days I spoke a bit of Romanian in
Austria at a reception and then I was in
Romania for about four days and being in
the real environment it's it's not just
that you hear words many of them you've
heard before and you're speaking some
and I was speaking some with my tutors
but I've had this experience before that
when you're in the real environment your
language learning and take a real jump
forward there was a fellow on our farm
at link who was talking about going to
France and hoping that he would be able
to really improve his French while there
and I said in my experience he will
because you're now in a situation where
you're not talking to a tutor who speaks
to you slowly and who's understanding
and and whom you've paid you're talking
to people at the train station in the
shops who may or may not be patient may
or may not phrase
or pronounce things carefully and you've
got to respond to it and you're
surrounded by the language and the
newspapers on the radio and it's just a
different feeling although something the
language is not an academic exercise
it's real it's something you need to
communicate and it just changes the way
your your mind deals with the language
so much of language learning I believe
is it has to do with your emotions and
your attitudes toward the language do
you like the language do you not like
the language are you confident not
confident and of course this sense of
being in a real situation with the
language really can propel you forward
however there are some conditions I
firmly believe that if you are not
prepared if you go into a store and
someone barks something out you and you
haven't a chance to understand what
they're saying you know or I mean I was
again in Romania I had factory visit one
day and then we visited these
monasteries magnificent monasteries up
in the northern part of Moldova and then
the next day I had a car driver because
in Romania if you rent a car for another
20 euros a day you can get a driver so
we were six hours in the car six hours
we were speaking Romanian the whole way
now had I not been prepared I couldn't
possibly
I mean once I get past my name is how
old are you that's it if I don't have a
sufficient preparation so I firmly
believe that to take advantage of a
visit to a country and to get that
thrust forward in your in your language
skills prepare yourself ahead of time
and I've done this before I did it with
check-check took a lot longer than
Romanian because of of the greater
complexity and the fact that Romanian
has a lot of you know freebie words from
French and Italian and so forth but it's
the same idea you focus on the fact that
we're going to go somewhere and then you
prepare ahead of time then when you go
there you have this major breakthrough
because you're sufficiently well
prepared you know and I'm gonna ramble a
bit here but I was in a restaurant
locally here and one of our waitresses
had studied Mandarin for a year in a
high school here in Vancouver
and we with a Chinese couple and so we
said well can you say anything and so
she turned to the Chinese couple and all
she could say was washer Sarah nature
say in other words I'm Sarah who are you
first of all that's extremely polite you
don't speak to people like that you know
what's your name even in English you
know in the way seeing in Chinese but
that's all she had which is kind of sad
a year is a long time you can learn a
lot in a year now granted she's not very
motivated although her father's Chinese
her mother's you know not Chinese she
should have been motivated but
motivation is key that's why so many
people in the French language programs
in Canada don't learn because they're
not very motivated so how do you make it
you know how do you motivate them well
you you make it real because the
pleasure that I derived from my albeit
brief four days in Romania was immense I
mean I met this mayor of a small town in
Vienna his small town is where one of
these sawmills is located that we deal
with and he made me change my schedule
instead of going to brush off I ended up
going to his little town called my nest
and then we had a dinner with different
kinds of cheese and Mitch and and stuff
like that and he was such a nice guy
kissed me on both cheeks every time I
met him and then he insisted that I take
his car and driver a little little
Volkswagen is not like a limousine or
anything to go the next day to Sibiu
through the mountains which was like a
nine-hour Drive and he wouldn't say not
take no for an answer
and that's just one example of how
tremendously nice people were towards me
I was in Sibiu and the Sun was beating
down I didn't have a hat and I get
headaches from the Sun and I managed to
find this secondhand shop and they had a
little hat there but I mean we had a
lovely conversation and in Romania
people speak English well many people
speak English well she spoke English
well in fact this particularly was
married to someone from South America
but we had a great conversation and in
remaining and people were just so
friendly so you come away with this
wonderful experience like you've made
new friends it's
it's it's I'm unfortunately I shouldn't
say unfortunately but I have to go back
and concentrate on on Korea now because
I said I'm gonna learn that language but
it's it's it's always like this every
time you've had this brief fling with a
language Russian Czech Romanian I'm very
reluctant to leave it because I had so
many pleasant experiences associated
with the language but there are real
situations and that's why I think that
to prepare yourself for those real
situations I still think that intensive
listening and reading and building up
your vocabulary is the way to go you can
do it wherever you are you can do it on
your own you can follow your interests
if you're listening to and reading
things of interest it's meaningful more
meaningful than in a classroom where
they have role playing or what they call
task based language learning let's
pretend that you are buying groceries or
let's pretend that you are the checkout
girl and I find these things artificial
and not meaningful I far rather in my
interactions with my tutors just talk
about whatever we can come up with
whatever interests us that day
that's real therefore it's a real
meaningful what did you do today but she
asked me about my job I asked her we
talked about the politics we talked
about anything rather than trying to
artificially pretend that I walk in a
store if you have this broad base in the
language if you have a lot of words if
you've been listening the brain has
started to get used to hearing where
words begin and end picking up on
certain phrases if you go into the store
the first time somebody barks something
out - you don't get it but the next time
you go into that store you'll be ready
and then you'll be encountering then in
the real life a variety of these
situations you'll be sitting in on a you
know triangular conversation and slowly
starting to pick up on it and so I guess
what I'm saying is that that having a
real life goal of visiting the country
one of the countries where the language
is spoken throwing yourself into that
real life situation is tremendously
beneficial to you
it gives you so much more enjoyment in
terms of visiting the country then you
could possibly have if you didn't speak
the language it becomes a very concrete
goal that can motivate you in your
language learning but you have to
prepare for it and artificial
role-playing and pretending that you're
at the bank and other artificial
scenarios to my mind is not as good a
way of preparing as massive listening
and reading on subject of interest then
followed up with natural meaningful
conversations meaningful interactions
with native speakers which you can
initiate therefore via Skype and then
eventually hopefully going to the
country now not everyone can afford to
do that I realize that but in today's
day and age there's more and more
opportunities to travel cost of
traveling has come down and you can
always try to look for people in your
own community that speak the language
but I tell you my visit to Romania it
was very brief but I still have this
very fond feeling about my experience in
Romania and sometime this week I'm gonna
put up a discussion with my one of my
Romanian tutors and we are also going to
have it translated and the translation
will appear as captions underneath so
you'll get more information about my
visit to Romania and you'll be able to
judge how far or how quickly we can
advance in the language with this
combination of massive input a little
bit of online conversation in
preparation and then immersion for
unfortunately again only four days
obviously if it were a month that would
be a lot better so thank you for
listening and we will talk again
bye for now